hello i'm donald faison I'm six feet  tall  six one with shoes on auditioning for  lando calrissian Junior  I hated when Dad goes on and on and on  about blasting a wampa on Hoth I'm like  oh man you aren't even at the Battle of  Hoth so shut up listen dad I got some  bad news I borrowed your speeder and I  accidentally may have hit two or three  Ewoks father listen I know you said my  mom died when I was just a kid but be  honest is my mom Princess Leia you had  that didn't you keep it real my name is  Lando Calrissian Junior  no no not the Lando who ran Cloud City  or helped rescue Luke Skywalker from the  evil clutches of Jabba the Hutt I'm  Lando who drinks Colt 45 malt liquor  baby EP colt 45 parsecs carbon freeze  cold  [Laughter]